the Joe Rogan experience I just told you
that let's not give you all these
capsules you won't see daylight till
tomorrow
okay the THC Capitals Oh what's in there
a bee is [ __ ] ash or a little bit of
oxygen milligrams of THC how many you
takin I can pop two in the afternoon 200
milligrams then take another 200 tonight
and I'll be okay once no I got this new
thing called quick Zee click see quick
Zee what is that it's a little towards
container if you want to sleep you come
see me
quick Zee quick Zee what's in it
melatonin like triple and they did not
put you to sleep naturally mm-hmm
they've put it in there plus a hundred
milligrams IV the sativa indica or a
hybrid marijuana whoa and you drink it
dawg your first night I drank it I found
myself usually I fall asleep like you do
like this writing reading the computer
and you have this yeah that's a B is
this one I'm away from the computer
right I actually back away and then
slump have you done that one joke sure
I've done that once you have yeah last
week no two weeks ago I got so [ __ ]
out cuz I thought I was when we go to
New York and die from the Corolla but I
actually drank that [ __ ] I ate two pills
oh my god I ate two of these first
nothing happened I drank the [ __ ]
liquid and something started to happen
but it wasn't going fast enough it was
like 10:15 I wanted this time to go to
bed so I popped to Morty oh oh my god I
all hit me at once like a Larry Holmes
[ __ ] left hook that night I woke up
on the floor I fell off the chair and
the heater woke me up I have a healer my
office my birth my back was on fire I'm
like why am I on fire
right
I woke up dog in a trance I went into
the kitchen I opened up the refrigerator
I pulled out a half a pound the deluxe
boy at Jesus she had just bought an
American cheese
I took a pact of saltine crackers
because of my mind I'm not even bread
I'm okay
I'm not eating bread I'm ahead of this
[ __ ]
Wow and the whole thing of American
cheese slice then I took off my mass it
was a big chunk of American cheese in
the sleep apnea mask once - oh my god
what the [ __ ] last night
I [ __ ] went out my wife I Joey what
was I thinking
you have no idea what I was going
through [ __ ] I didn't get into both
before the morning I went to bed at 4:00
in the [ __ ] like I woke up at 3:30 and
was like what the [ __ ]
oh my god I must have went down at a
quarter to 11:00 I had been I probably
was in this position for an hour and I
just fell off the [ __ ] stool and just
laying on the floor nobody saw me that's
how drilled by God
[Applause]